there they are the best actresses of
1968 Katherine happened in the line in
winter Patricia Neal for the subject was
roses vanessa redgrave
Frieza Dora Barbra Streisand fan eager
Joanne Woodward Rachel Rachel the winner
it's a tie the winners are Katharine
Hepburn in Lion in the winter and Barbra
Streisand
this is Anthony Harvey who is accepting
the award for Katherine
when I asked him his head bum what she
thought when she had broken the record
for
winningly breaking the records for
nominations she said I suppose if I've
lived as long as I have anything can
happen
and I'm absolutely thrilled that it has
happened thank you very much
hello gorgeous I'm very honored to be in
such magnificent company as Katharine
Hepburn and she wins it so kind of a
wild feeling sitting there tonight I was
thinking that um the first script of
funny girl was written when I was only
11 years old and thank God it took so
long to get it right so I would I would
like to thank my my co-producer race
stock for waiting till I grew up and
Julie Steinem Bogner Alpha giving me
such a great score to sing and Isabelle
Leonard for writing such a terrific
character and all the Hollywood people
who made our show into a movie of her
bras and my dear Harry straddling who I
haven't let go since and my dear friend
and director William Wyler
well it's like hmm somebody once said to
me asked me if I was happy
and I I said are you kidding I'd be
miserable if I was happy and I'd like to
thank all the members of the Academy for
making me really miserable